- On this episode we talk delegation,
we talk the value of languages,
and we get really deep on the thoughts
of passive income.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee show.
Hey, everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 86 of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
We're gonna try to bumrush this episode
because I'm on my way
to Copenhagen to speak,
doing a little European travel,
got Madrid next week.
And Matt and I had a miscommunication,
so I don't have my passport,
so he's gonna go run
and get it.
It's been a little hectic here.
Big ups to Meerkat, what's up everyone?
And, uh, oh, the gang
met Lizzie yesterday.
That was fun, watching you
guys interact with Lizzie,
I enjoyed it.
She's like, I got home, she was like,
'cause I had a meeting after
our little Crain's 40 for 40
thing, which is why she was here.
She's like, "Man, India's hair is long."
I'm like, it sure is.
India, let's get into the show.
By the way, before we go into the show,
and keep this rolling, DRock,
VaynerNation, I'm really
enjoying, you know,
I had a few minutes to look at this,
the interaction between the VaynerNation
and you guys is super fun for me to watch.
You know, I also got a random email,
like, "Hey, can you get me India's email?
"I have a project I need
to speak to her about."
I'm like, I'm air
traffic control to India?
What the (beep) is going on here?
Something is clearly happening here
and it's magic.
All right, let's go.
- [Voiceover] Denni asks,
"Gary, do you have any tips
"on delegation?"
- Denni, you know, I
actually think the best piece
of advice that I can give
to delegating is actually
going to be very much up in the clouds,
and as you know, I like
the clouds and the dirt.
DRock, link it up.
I think I'm tremendous at delegating
and I'll tell you the number
one rule to delegation,
recognizing that 99.9% of things
don't mean shit.
If you actually think
it's not that important,
it becomes a hell of a lot easier to let
somebody else do it.
If you recognize somebody
else's 7.7 skills
is better off because
that job is worth that,
versus your 10.0 skills,
it's humility, my friend.
Ego oftentimes is the
issue with delegation.
Even though I have a ton of ego,
I have a boatload more
humility than you think.
- [Voiceover] Tommy asks,
"Gary, isn't working long hours
"an old school mind set?
"Why not focus on building
wealth via passive income?"
- You know, Tommy, I think both work.
You know, I think that when people say,
"Hey, let's do passive
income," they go into
Spam City, USA oftentimes.
You know, I have passive
income when I'm investing
in early stage startups
that then go sell for 400X
and I didn't do anything, I made money,
shit, I made more money
on my passive income,
probably, than my hustle income.
They both work but please
make sure that your
passive income has practicality to it
because all the people who
have tried to create systems
and automate their cash,
there's been a very small
percentage of people that have
been able to lay on the beach
while they collect money on the internet.
A lot of that stuff is
completely ludicrous
and I promise you the ones
in the 1% of passive income
spent a boatload of
hard work and hard time
to get to that evergreen
place up in the sky.
And so, you know,
I think that there's an enormous, massive,
misunderstanding that there are (scoffs)
almost zero people that
have pulled off substantial
success without putting
in real time and effort.
Now, we all have different
ambitions and goals.
Do I think that it's easier
to create $60,000 a year
in passive income on the internet today?
I sure do and if that's where
your goal and ambition is,
that's more practical than millions.
Millions of dollars in passive
income on the internet,
smoking (beep) weed in
Jamaica while it just
keeps coming in is just not
as real as you think, partner.
(laughing)
You like that one?
I'm right, because that's
what everybody thinks it is
and it's just not real.
(beep) Show me,
'cause I'll show you a billion people that
have won through hard work.
Show me.
Show me this magical person,
'cause I'll show you
somebody who sells you
that dream but isn't actually doing it.
That, I'll show you.
You want me to hire some
models for the afternoon
and get a boat and go to
some sunny (beep) place
and be like, this is it?
I'll show you that.
You want me to show you
the people on Instagram
who go take all the money
they own in the world
in $100 forms in the bank
and throw it on a bed
and take a picture and then
put it back in their bank?
I'll show you that.
I'll show you the front of
this passive income dream
of the internet.
Sorry.
- [Voiceover] The fuck outs
turned out a little too soft.
- Is that right?
You're happy I picked
up a little crescendo?
- [Staphon] More than a little bit.
- Is Meerkat liking the crescendo?
- It went out, it was
just audio for a while.
They could hear it but--
- [Gary] Got it, got it.
Wait 'til you see it.
- [Voiceover] Derek asks,
"Gary, what athlete,
"past or present,
embodies hustle for you?"
- Wayne Chrebet, 10th
guy on the depth chart
when he joined the Jets
in '95 in practice.
Got there because his dad hustled together
some VHS tapes, the Jets
sucked, so the coach
brought in anybody and his number
was retired last year.
That is incredible.
He looks like me, he's
a short, white dude.
He played through massive concussions.
I've gotten to know Wayne a
little bit in his post-career.
It's funny, I always felt like
Wayne was a little overrated,
'cause he was the little
white guy and I was like, ahh,
that's racist, or you know,
but his hustle is insanity.
And so, I have enormous
amounts of respect for him
and he absolutely is the
answer to that question.
- [Voiceover] Thomas asks,
"Gary, what value do you find
"in knowing a foreign language?"
- Thomas, (speaking in foreign language).
You're laughing at me because
the way I speak Russian
is so hardcore English
accent and struggle,
but it's interesting, I failed German
and the only reason I
even graduated high school
is 'cause my Spanish teacher
is the greatest of all time
and she just knew that I had it.
And big shout out to Senora Kennedy,
the one teacher that
really holds a hardcore
place in my heart because
truly, in New Jersey,
you have to graduate two years of language
and by failing out of German, my freshman
and sophomore year, I
needed a miracle to pass
Spanish 1 and 2 in my
junior and senior year.
And God was very good to
me for giving me a teacher
that had a tough reputation
but clearly, she was
smart as shit 'cause she
actually knew who I was.
She literally called my mom and was like,
I'm giving your son a C for charisma,
but you need to know, he doesn't even know
how to say "hello" in Spanish.
And so, I don't put a
lot of value on knowing
other languages.
Maybe that's 'cause of
my own personal prejudice
of being someone who struggled
learning another one,
even though I got two from
at least a hearing standpoint
and I can communicate.
You throw me in Moscow for a month,
that Russian you just heard
will get a hell of a lot better
as my ear and tongue get adapted to it.
I also think technology is now coming
where we're gonna be able to translate,
clearly, in a decade, I'll
be able to go to China
and just be like, or like talk into here
or just, it's in it, or
put in the ear pieces.
Does anybody not know that we're gonna put
ear pieces in when we
go to foreign countries
and we're just all
gonna talk our languages
and everything's gonna
be translated proper?
And so the value I put on it has gone down
in value as I recognize
technology's gonna fix that issue.
- [Voiceover] Benjamin asks,
"Gary, I want to start pushing
"people to make the same decision I made
"by leaving a very secure
job to pursue their dream.
"My question is, will my
employee retention rate drop?
"Since you started building
up your personal brand,
"has your employee
retention rate dropped?"
- Benjamin, the thing you
need to understand is that
intent trumps everything.
And so I think one amazing
thing in this company
that I'm extremely proud
of is I truly believe
that these people that
work at VaynerMedia
really recognize that I want to win
but not at their expense.
I want to buy the Jets, not at
the expense of my employees,
with my employees and I equally
want what's best for them.
Of course, you know,
looking at these three,
and things are running through my mind
and, obviously, I know them
all at different levels,
but you know, there's
narratives in my mind
that I can play out right
now that leads to a world
of them not being here.
And that makes me sad and I really
don't want that.
And from an ego standpoint,
I truly believe that I
can bring them so much
value over the long haul
that makes it interesting
for them to stay.
But I think it's massively
important that they always,
deep down, feel as though I want them
to have what they want,
even though, optically,
it doesn't benefit me.
And I would say 40% of
VaynerMedia believes that.
And that may surprise you as a low number,
but I hope you understand
the level of cynicism
that is instilled in us as human beings
to not believe everything I just said.
And so I'm massively proud of the 40%
and I'm really pumped
that I think that 40%
was actually 12% only 12 to 18 months ago
and so I'm building momentum, right?
Look, I think if you're
scared to lose somebody
who believes in their heart that they have
the skill set to go and do it,
you're making a huge
mistake and I actually think
you build retention by
showing them the reverse.
It's a reverse psychology
game that is not a tactic
because if you don't actually believe it,
that reverse psychology
will come across as bullshit
and you'll lose it.
I don't do it because I want
to reverse psychology India,
I do it because I believe it.
And then they have to believe
and evolve in their place.
You know, I believe that
the evolution of people
not being here is gonna
have a lot more to do
with things in life, they
fall in love and get married,
and have to move 'cause
their spouse really needs
to do this and they have
the empathy and being
the bigger man or woman
in the relationship
to go let their spouse do that,
unfortunately, maybe something tragic.
I actually think that when you're pure,
when you want to win but
you want to win with,
not, you know, on the
back of, people start
sticking around because the truth is,
if somebody works at a
job, in a lot of ways,
they weren't thinking
purely, I'm gonna put this
on my back to begin with, right?
And you, and I don't know your age,
is there a picture, or
is this a written word?
- [India] Oh, this is written.
- You know, I don't know
your age, but again,
if you're over 30, you were
sold on a world where it wasn't,
I'm gonna go do my own thing, right?
So now that we live in
that world, I actually feel
that the kids that are going
to work for companies now
in lieu of entrepreneurship
are truly not entrepreneurs.
Back into that big argument of
entrepreneur-like tendencies
and entrepreneurship,
I'll tell you right now,
show me a 23-year-old
that wants to work here
and I'll show you somebody
who is, got entrepreneurial
tendencies but isn't pure entrepreneur.
So I just think doing
the right thing is always
the right thing and I think
empowering your people
to follow their dreams if
they have one, if they think
they're good enough, if
they are willing to deal
with the stress and all the
dog shit that comes along
with having all the
pressure on your shoulder,
then, you know, you empower
them and root for them
and try to be part of that narrative.
But if they have tendencies,
what you're doing is
actually building a deeper
relationship with that person,
and actually, my belief
is that percentage,
you're creating longer term.
I mean, the stickiness of this company
is pretty intense,
given the agency world's
a tough place for stickiness
and so I'm very proud of that
and you know what I spew.
Great last question. Question of the day,
what is the, right in
front of you, right now,
what is the clear dream that you have?
What's the one thing
you want to accomplish
that is crystal clear and it will evolve,
it might be different than
it was six months ago,
it's gonna be different in six years,
but right this second,
as you watch this show,
what's the one thing
you want to accomplish?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep brilliantly answering them.
You like that?